We have been looking at the question of
the rise of the Poles and the various
significant elements that were
part of the making of the poles.
And of course I've emphasized the notion
of this new class of people the former
hotplate
citizen as being the critical element
in shaping the poles and for my money.
That's what the Poles
is about to start with.
And then it develops characteristics
consistent with that and some that
challenge that over the centuries.
But now imagine that we are living in
the early years of the poles sometime in
the 8th century B.C..
Again I want to emphasize these things
that I've been describing don't happen
every place at the same time and they
don't even happen every place in the same
way.
But over a stretch of time
the concepts and the kind
of characteristics I've
been describing appear to
spread all over the place.
But one of the ways in which we can date
the time when the Poles came into being
has to do with the Greek traditions
about the establishment of colonies
throughout the Mediterranean inhabited
by Greeks and the reason that they are a
clue is because every time we see a
colony learn anything at all about it
it appears to exist in the form of a
polis which powerfully suggests that that
was the sort of the typical characteristic
style of life that had already been
established for Greeks before
they sent out colonies.
So that's the chronological
significance of it all I should say.
All of these dates that I will be
giving you are some combination of Greek
tradition and the Greeks dated many in
many cases they dated these colonies very
specifically.
That would be hard to believe
impossible to believe I guess.
If it weren't that these dates tended to
be confirmed in a general way not in a
specific way by the archeological
discoveries that we find at the sites the
earliest places where these
colonies came into being.
So it's that combination archaeology
plus Greek tradition that lies behind the
date of any city.
But you shouldn't take the date that I
give you the traditional date as being
firm.
It's a general thing it's around that
time is the best we can really say to
date.
That's sort of typical for the general
phenomenon of colonisation coming out of
the mother cities of Greece is again that
date we keep talking about 750 roughly.
But in fact the earliest date according
to Greek tradition if my memory is
correct was something like seven
seventy three where the Greeks date the
foundation of what they thought was the
earliest colony they ever established
place that they called Perfect Koussa
which we call it's the island of SGA in
the Bay of Naples.
That's the very first place where there
is a tradition of a Greek colony having
been planted.
There's no question that there was a
Greek colony there and and as I say the
archaeological remains confirm the
general time for this happening.
Now the first question I suppose is but
before I get to describing what a colony
was and how it worked.
We want to ask the question What was it
that led Greeks to sail or walk most of
this sail very great distances from
their mother cities to leave home and to
establish a new city for
themselves someplace else.
That is not to be taken for granted in
the first place by until the twentieth
century I guess human
beings tended to stay put.
They didn't move unless
they were driven to move.
That was the natural thing to do given
the character of life which was based
upon farming.
If you leave you lose your farm based
upon the difficulty of transportation in
the Greek world we know I think I quoted
something from he that confirm it.
The Greeks were even though they went
to see plenty they were terrified of the
sea for a very good reason their ships
their boats were not very seaworthy.
Storms come up in the Mediterranean
very suddenly and terribly.
You take your life in your
hands when you travel.
So then there is the whole idea you know
we've already given you some sense that
the Greeks were ancestor worshippers.
I mean they took special care of the
dead and they thought that the way you
buried people and so on
was terribly important.
And so what I'm saying is when you leave
the place where you were born you will
leave your ancestors as well.
All of that means we need to explain why
these folks do what they end up doing
and we have some hints but of course we
do not know with any certainty or any
confidence.
If you ask the question why did many
Italians leave their home especially south
Italians in the late 19th century and
come well go all over the world actually
South America Australia. But the
largest numbers to the United States.
Why did they do that. Well we
don't have to do a lot of guessing.
We have written evidence from the people
who went and they say why they did it.
We can then supplement that with all sorts
of other information that we have but
we don't have any documents from some
settler explaining why he's going where
he's going.
So we have to reason from the evidence
that the establishment gives us.
I suppose the most widely cited reason
is simply the desire to acquire farmland
remember.
I keep emphasizing this the
vast overwhelming majority
of people needed to farm
land in order to stay alive.
And why should there be
a shortage of farm land.
One answer and that's the one that is
most widely believed among Greek scholars
is that the growth of population that
we have mentioned in connection with the
rise of the poles is still working.
Once the Poles comes
into form and so what.
What this means if you are producing.
If you have used to had two
children and now you have four.
How do you provide for the extra two.
Well you know some.
Sometimes you divide up the land equally
but if that land continues to get
smaller and smaller it will not
sustain an additional person.
Not to mention additional family.
If you were to follow the procedure
which the Greeks did not of primogeniture
that is of giving the whole
plot to the eldest son.
But what happens to the others.
And so that clearly is a problem.
And the notion that land hunger is a key
explanation I think is supported by the
fact that wherever we find a pulse
whatever other characteristics it has and
they vary some of them are located at
wonderful places on the sea for trading
purposes some of them are not but all
of them have a land supply which permits
the citizens to farm successfully and
thereby to keep the make the polis
succeed.
But I don't think that's the only answer.
I think that desire for commerce
would have been also I agree with the
traditional view which is that this
would've been a lesser consideration but
still very important
because we so often find.
That the colony is placed right out of
a nifty place for trade and they would
have had to be damn fools to have
several there without that being in their
mind.
So although some of the places where
they settled leave us puzzled and it left
the ancients puzzled.
One of my favorite example is the colony
on the south shore of the Bosporus
which is called Chelsea then Calcutta
on whichever way you want to do it.
It's right opposite Constantinople
and no constant. That doesn't exist.
Istanbul Winston Churchill never
never conceded that it was Istanbul.
He called it Constantinople
to the day he died.
But right opposite that magnificent
sight the Golden Horn is there.
How could you possibly settle
there because they settled
Chelsea then first and
the tradition that the Greeks pass on
is the people who settle Chelsea on war
blind men because you would have
to be blind to make that choice.
But we don't know why
they did what they did.
So but nonetheless the desire for a good
commercial opportunity might well have
been one of the elements that these
people who were leaving their home cities
sought. And then there are less.
What's the word I want.
Certainly things that have nothing
to do with economics really.
We always there are always there were
politics going on in these states as there
always are.
In any Greek polls there are factions
that grow up for one reason or another.
They come into conflict.
One side wins the argument and the battle
and sometimes the ill will is so great
that the losing fought side feels either
that it has to flee for its safety or
that it chooses to flee rather
than to live under their opponents.
And so you would have.
Defeated political groups might well or
individuals who were the heads of those
groups might decide they have to get
out of town and now that we do have
something this wave of colonization
they join that as well.
And then there are always things that
we might call much less rational than
that.
In any group of people.
There is a small minority
I want to emphasize small
who'd just love to do risky
things they just love adventure.
They're never happy if they're safe.
And so off to go seeking adventure and
seeking to make a fortune however they're
going to do it. So I think that has
to be counted into the picture too.
So typically I think it would have
been a small part of what's going on.
So for these reasons and probably for a
hundred more that I haven't thought of.
We can understand why these people go
against the natural instinct of staying
put and go of adventuring out seeking a
new home someplace in the Mediterranean.
OK.
What are these new settlements like.
First thing is that they're like each
other in many important ways although
obviously with differences
from place to place.
But here's how it works by the way.
The word I have been using colony is not
a Greek word and really not appropriate
for what the Greeks are up to.
The Greek word for this is up or a key
out and most literally it would mean a
home away and away home.
And that's what they're making they're
re-establishing themselves a household a
home someplace away
from where they started.
And that's the name colony is a Latin
word ultimately for colonia and the Roman
colonies were first of all garrisons
that they planted in land they had
conquered to keep the people quiet.
So they would be alien bosses
in a different territory.
And then later in history in Roman
history that was the name given to
establishment rural establishments.
When the civilization was breaking down
and they had and the men who worked on
those rural places really were not free
men and were the antecedents of the
service.
We will see later on in
medieval history in Europe.
So when you see the word colonia in
late Roman history it's talking about
something very very different
from what we're talking about. So.
I use the word count because that's what
we have for all such establishments of
the kind we're talking about
but I remember that these
are appoint key from the
Greek point of view.
OK.
How does an upward Keya happen
somebody in one of the old Greek cities
has to decide that he wants to go out
and establish a colony.
He would be an individual of some
eminence because the job of doing this
requires that people should accept.
His leadership.
He will have to do the recruiting of
people that come with him on the colony.
He will have to do the constitutional
discussion and political discussion to
gain the sanction from the mother city
to allow him to do everything he knows.
So I think we should imagine that these
colonies these leaders of colonies these
founders of colonies
would be probably noblemen
and that they would have a
position of eminence but and yet.
Unlikely to be part of the sort of
dominant faction in that city because
otherwise why would they leave anyway.
The Greeks had a name for this individual.
He was called an OI c'est states.
He is the founder of the colony so now
he has decided to do it and he's gained
recognition from the town council
let's say. And he can go forward.
Now he has to have an idea.
He did.
He can't just say I think I'd like to
found a colony but is more typical I think
is that he thinks I would like to take
and I've found a colony on the south
eastern coast of Sicily Y.
Because he knows something about it.
Either he has somehow traveled out
there himself and said take the place.
I'm thinking about.
Has a wonderful harbor.
It has good farmland in the neighborhood.
A critical element to making this
judgment is it is not occupied by hostile
natives who will resist vigorously.
Your landing there either there will be
nobody there or more likely there will
be not a very big population
and it's not very tough.
And they could be easily brushed aside
those would have been some of the
considerations.
And so what the orchestra is does when
he has picked out in his own mind where
he wants to go next he
goes to Delphi anybody.
You raise your hand if you've been to
Delphi Yeah well it's when you go to
Greece do the obvious go
where the tourists go.
And Delphi is one place not to miss
it's halfway up Mount Parnassus.
And it was thought by the
Greeks to be the on fellows.
The navel of the universe
the center in every way.
Why.
Because they're the God Apollo
had established a an oracle.
There were there was a place
in which from the earth there came
a star wasn't steam what it was.
What would it be gases would
escape through this gap in
the earth and there when
things got figured out and arranged and
there were priests who worshiped Apollo
there and who took care
of this phenomenon.
There was if they would place a
young woman there who would sit.
As these gases came up.
And she would.
After a while begin to I suppose in the
biblical languages she would speak in
tongues which is to say she would rattle
off a lot of language which nobody
could understand what she was saying
gibberish or so it sounded or Greek making
no sense to anybody.
And then the priest would listen to this
stuff and he would say Ah what Apollo
said through the priest is here is.
And he would give the message
let me just take a moment to tell you
about this I say this now with great
confidence.
But ten years ago this story which all
the Greeks agreed to have agreed upon in
every respect the temple of Apollo was
built right on top of this underneath the
floor of the temple was this little room
where the gases came up with a priest
who sat through all of this came up.
Well archaeologists investigated this
carefully the French school of archaeology
late in the 19th century dug everything
up and concluded this was baloney.
It was a myth.
There were no gases coming up
from any of this stuff. And.
So everybody believed for the next century
and then a young man who once sat in
one of the chairs not in this room
maybe but that in which you're sitting.
John Hale of the Yale class of
nineteen seventy three who is now an
archaeologist at the
University of Louisville
having learned or having agreed let's
say with my prejudice which is that the
higher now used Hey must reign.
And if the Greeks said it happened you
got to believe it happened until you have
to believe that it didn't happen.
And so we decided to investigate this and
he took with him a fine geologist from
Wesleyan and justice to go to the place
there at Delphi and to see whether it
could be true that such
gases did come out.
And what sort of gases they were and
what consequences they would have.
And you know I wouldn't be telling you
this story if it hadn't turned out that
they discovered evidence
that in my judgment.
But I don't think really
anybody doubts it anymore.
Totally confirmed the Greek story. I can
tell you precisely what the gases were.
What the characteristics of those gases
were squared beautifully with all the
tales that we heard
about the Delphic oracle.
So here's just one more case where Yale
helped to straighten out the world.
But you notice it wasn't done by Yale
faculty member we we engage in confusing
the world but our alumni do a much
better job and that's what happened here.
So. So you go to the Oracle and what
do you say. What do you ask the oracle.
Well now before we go any further you
will in your Herodotus readings and
elsewhere you will come across many a
story in which an Oracle is consulted and
gives an answer.
Well the most famous early on King Croesus
of Lydia the richest man in the world
you've heard all about him decides it
would be a nice thing to conquer the
Persian empire his neighbor to the east
and so he goes to the east a barbarian
but the barbarians came to the Delphic
Oracle to because you want to know what
the gods want.
So he came and he asked.
He said if I if I cross the Halley's River
that's the boundary between Libya and
Persia what will happen
and the Oracle replied.
A great empire will be destroyed.
And presses it. Terrific.
That's what I have in mind.
He invaded he was clobbered.
And then you read a splendid story
about it just tells of how here he was
captured.
He was up on a pyre.
He was going to be burned
when he remembered so long.
The Greek would come to him and
warned him about this vain glory.
And he said oh so long and oh so long
and I guess Apollo must have then said Ah
he's read.
He's reached wisdom and so he sent a
rainstorm to put the fire out and he lived
through that.
Well OK.
But the point is the Oracle was wrong.
No of course not.
We all know what was wrong with creases.
He should have asked another question
which empire but didn't think of it.
Other times you know all kinds of funny
stories told about the Oracle which
would suggest that it wasn't really a
very reliable source of information that
it was filled with knowledge
mythology and so on and so forth.
But here it is the hard headed fact we
know for sure Greeks and barbarians and
everybody came to Delphi when you came
to Delphi and you were going to consult
the oracle. It was hard. A
lot of people a long line.
So there was a waiting issue but also
people used to bribe the priest in order
to get up more more upfront online and
they would also give great and beautiful
gifts to the temple people and
to the temple and to the priest.
And in other words people spent a
lot of money to consult the oracle.
Now ask yourself this especially you're
talking about Greeks are they going to
keep shelling out money for an oracle
that gives them answers that turn out to
be wrong.
No.
Most of the things they asked
were questions that really
had a yes or no answer.
And according according to my thinking
there's no way they could have been wrong
very much.
And I think the Oracle probably gained
its fame for being very good at precisely
at answering this question.
The question would have been what will
happen if I go and try to settle a colony
at the place which I will call Syracuse.
That's what I've been describing on
the southeastern coast of Sicily.
And the answer would come back and the
priests would give a response that would
be essentially straight.
It would either say something like I'm
not going to do the words that they would
have come up with but they would have
said yep that's a good place to go.
And if or no don't do that.
That's a terrible mistake.
Now why would they be able to do that.
Because at some point in here
Delphi really did become the navel
of the universe. Everybody came.
Now you can bet when these folks came
and consulted the priest and said Could
you please put us down on the list
we want to consult the oracle.
The priest said sure have a beer.
Let's talk about your hometown.
What's going on out there.
What I'm suggesting to you that this
was the best information gathering and
storing device that existed
in the Mediterranean world.
These people knew more than
anybody else about these things.
And so consulting that Oracle
was a very rational act indeed.
OK.
Now suppose you are annoyed orchestrates
you've gotten the permission from your
city to go forward.
You go to the Delphic Oracle
and the other car says fine.
By all means go where you want to go.
Next thing you've got to go home and
you have to write up what amounts to a
charter of foundation for the city which
lays out how things are going to work
in this city.
Something about the governmental structure
maybe even more fundamentally how the
land will be a lot of assigned divided
and so on so that when you go to recruit
settlers everybody will know what he's
getting and we'll decide whether it's
it's a good idea for him or not.
Now recruiting is tremendously
important because you need to have.
A certain number of settlers
to make the settlement viable.
You may not run into.
An enormously powerful collection of
natives but you're gonna get some kind of
trouble.
It's foolish for you to assume you're not
going to have any problem out there so
you need a certain number of
people just for defense purposes.
But beyond that you need to have a certain
number of people to carry out all the
functions that need to be carried
out for a successful post.
So however many that is that is what
you try to recruit and you recruit
typically it would be at a time when it's
easy to get people together so you can
tell them the story. And the best
time would be at some great festival.
There are festivals held in each
city just for its own citizens.
And my guess is that when you could do
that when you felt that you could recruit
a full colony from your fellow
citizens in Corinth let us say.
That's what you did.
But it would often happen that there were
not enough Corinthians who were ready
to go with you on your expedition so you
would try to have to take your message
to one of the pan hellenic festivals
which were getting organized about this
time as you know the Olympic Games
are alleged to have started in 1776.
So that would be a place where Greeks
from all over might come and you could
then try to recruit settlers
for your new colony there.
And we don't know precisely when but
there were important pan hellenic games at
near Corinth the isthmus in games that
were pan hellenic games at Delphi and
there were a pan hellenic games in the
north eastern Peloponnese at a town
called Noumea.
So.
There would always be some opportunity
for you to go out and make your pitch so
now you have everything in place you've
recruited your settlements you get on
your ships and sail.
In this case out to the western West
Central Mediterranean you find your way to
Sicily work your way into
the harbor at Syracuse.
And things work out.
And now we have this boy Keya called
Syracuse so the next question I think is
what is the relationship between Syracuse
which is the outpost here and the end
currents which is the main topless
the metropolis the mother city.
That's what metropolis means by the way.
First thing to brush from your mind along
with the word colony as we have used
it in modern times is the notion that.
The city of Syracuse would send out
a colony controlled owns the city of
Syracuse which it has sent out.
This is not the case.
But before they get the British gave
Hong Kong back Hong Kong was a Crown
Colony. It was British territory.
The Brit was ruled by Britain.
And so on.
No this is not what an eye here is from
the first Syracuse is an independent
policy autonomous self-governing
whatever regime it wants et cetera.
It is not a subject of anybody
not Corinth or anybody else.
But that's not the end of the story.
The question really is.
So now we know that what kind
of relations did they have.
I would say there are three categories
that they fall into the most typical the
usual.
Everything else is an exception.
Is that there are friendly relations
between the mother city and the upper IKEA
but they are just keep in mind always.
They are totally independent.
An example is the Peloponnesian War.
Syracuse finds itself besieged by the
Athenians they send to Corinth asking the
Corinthians please help us.
The Corinthians are free.
They will be violating
no law or sacred bond.
If they say Sorry we really
don't feel like doing that.
It would be thought they
were not behaving very well.
But they would have been
as I say perfectly within
every right you can imagine
to do that.
But the typical reaction would be that
the Corinthians would help to the extent
first of all that they could.
And secondly to the extent that it
was consistent with their interests.
Well in fact the Corinthians self sent
very little said a couple of ships and a
general which turned out to
be tremendously important
but they couldn't have
known that in advance from where we
said it looks like the Corinthians were
making a gesture of
friendship of solidarity.
The kind of thing you would expect a
mother city to do not to ignore its apathy
care when it was in trouble.
And so that's that's all that they did
and that it is a fairly first of all it
was normal. For the opera. Care to
turn to the mother city for help.
It was normal for the mother city to be
inclined to help if they could do it.
That's normal.
I think you if you imagine out of the
many many many colonies there were that
would have been the usual arrangement.
Now there are exceptions
in both directions and as
it happens the cases I know
best have to do with the city of Carmen's
current sent out a lot of colonies.
Which is why we know something about their
arrangements and the ones I'm talking
about all have to do with
the Peloponnesian War which
is one of the few reasons
one of the reasons why we know a little
bit about it because facilities tells us
the details of it.
Well we know thanks to facilities
that it had become normal for.
Currents to send out to its colony part
of DIA located on the Charles Citic
Peninsula you know those three fingers
sticking down into the Aegean Sea from
the mainland of Greece.
One of this is a town
on one of those fingers.
The part of the eye every year received
magistrates who govern their city from
currents. And this was not
imposed. This was not by force.
This was by mutual agreement.
So currents really had a very great deal
to say about what was going on and part
of the US so when part of the deal got
into trouble with Athens and found itself
besieged currents sent a real
army to go in there and fight.
And I think that's because of this very
special relationship that they had at
the other end of the spectrum.
It's again currents.
It has a colony up in the
Northwest called Coursera.
It is the modern island of Corfu
and this
colony was clearly established earlier
than 664 because that's the first time we
hear of it's taking any action it's been
around for a while. Very early colony
and from the earliest times Coursera does
not get along with the mother city of
Khan.
The first relationship between them is
a naval battle and thereafter we hear of
them quarrelling and fighting with each
other just about at least once a century
right on down till we get
to the Peloponnesian War.
When a quarrel over who's who's won
out in that area between coronation and
Coursera is the I would say well it's the
first instigating element and bringing
on the Peloponnesian War.
OK so this gives you some idea of the
range of possible relationships between
colony and Mother City.
Just I want to emphasize one more time
that the overwhelming normal situation is
the first one I describe.
Friendly. Why not.
These guys that have gone out let us
say to Syracuse they are your people.
They have relatives back home.
They have friends back home.
It is natural.
Oh by the way they're accustomed to
worship the gods in the same way that the
Corinthians do.
We do know again two cities is our source
that it was customary for colonies to
send representatives back to the mother
city for the religious observations that
were common to them all.
So that doesn't create good feelings.
They feel like they're relatives and what
could be more natural you're out there
in Sicily and you discover of course
that you don't have all of the the things
that you used to have available
to you but used to be made.
Let us say in Corinth as a matter of fact
in the early days Corinth was a great
center of painted pottery and was the
leading producer and exporter of that.
So maybe you wanted a really fine part
of the kind of used to be able to walk to
the corner and pick up at a pottery.
But you can't get now so you would
want to buy what the currency and sell.
Guess what. You've got great
greenfields out there in Syracuse.
Hard to believe today but Sicily was
one of the major granaries of the
Mediterranean world at that time.
Tremendously fruitful able to grow the
best possible crops very good wheat and
so on.
Khan's always needs that kind of stuff.
So we sell you are wheat you sell us your
pottery you sell us good wine that we
can't grow yet and maybe never we'll
be able to grow in our neighborhood.
So on and so forth.
So you can see why it would
be very natural for all
sorts of ties to unite these
colony and Mother City.
Maybe I would just give you a chance.
Before I turn the next question to ask
any questions that still are not clear
for you about this phenomenon
of colonization. Everybody OK.
Yes.
Question is who used it.
Who gave permission for a
colony to go in the Mother City.
The best guess and that's the only
thing I think we have would be.
These would have been
aristocratic republics.
At this stage of the game and so there
would have been a Council of Nobles that
would typically have done it.
As you move later in their history you
find you can guess that there would be
councils that were not purely of nobles
but might be of wealthy people but they
would always be a minority
and come from the upper class.
I think that would be where they would
get their legitimacy in the back. Yeah.
A primitive form of what.
I did.
I'm not sure that that concept makes it.
No the answer is no because nobody
was compelled to do anything.
You know the British practicing
mercantilism were passed
navigation acts saying
what ships could carry water and so on.
Nothing like that in the Greek world.
Everybody. All of this is voluntary
on both sides of every agreed.
OK now where are these colonies.
Let me give you a little
rundown before we get to that.
I should say that the Greeks have already
before this period of the polis and
the period of colonization which is
connected with the rise of the poles
centuries before that the Greeks had
already spread out from their original
settlements.
Right after the collapse of the
masonry and world there was a period of
tremendous confusion and panic and fear
and so on so that we know that people
fleeing from whoever destroyed
the masonry and world.
Fled typically eastward into the island
among the islands of the Aegean Sea and
continuing on to the coast of Asia Minor
beyond them and so that by the 10th
century B.C. We see Greek cities lining
the coast of Asia Minor on the West and
even around on the bottom.
And to some degree on the north
and on the islands in the Aegean.
So there has been a Greek what's the word
I want an expansion of the Greek world
already.
By the 10th century.
And these folks are now settled down so
that some of these cities are in fact
among the most important cities
sending out colonies of their own.
Of these the most famous perhaps most
important was my leaders and Ionian city
located on the west coast of Asia Minor
which sent many a colony into different
parts of the world particularly up towards
the Straits and the Bosphorus and the
Sea of Marmara.
I might point out that the way the Greeks
did their emigration into Asia Minor.
They actually had a pattern so that you
can go from north to south and you will
find some consistency.
Here's what I mean.
The the northern most settlements on
that coast spoke Greek within Aeolian
dialect.
The I only I wrote the Ionian dialect is
the one that you see on the mainland in
places like Bosnia for
instance Thebes and so on.
South of the Ionian or Aeolian section
of that was the region of Asia Minor
inhabited chiefly by Iona ends.
The people on the mainland who are
the main Ionian obvious meanings.
And finally if you go to the most southern
part of the west coast of Asia Minor
you come to the Dorian speaking Greeks
and the whole pull up any source as you
know was fundamentally
a Dorian speaking place.
So that's the way the world looks
when the policies invented and when
colonization begins to become a big thing.
Now let's take a look at the world of
the Mediterranean and see how the Greek
expansion worked.
Let's start with the Aegean Sea.
Just almost all the islands in that sea
are inhabited by Greeks mostly by the
Greeks that came in that first wave of
emigrants earlier on not colonized during
the 8th century and afterwards but if
you go to the north shore of the Aegean
Sea into the region that the
Greeks called thrice. Sorry.
Before I even get to race maybe even a
little bit of Cecilie which is off mostly
to the west of the Aegean Sea.
A little bit but not thrice chiefly
which is the the northern shore of the
Aegean Sea. Lots of Greek colonies
there. It's fundamentally part of Greece.
Yeah.
This is not a bad time for me to remind
you that in one of Plato's dialogues
dialogues Socrates says
the Greeks sit like.
Frogs around a pond.
And that pond is the Aegean Sea.
It's a helpful little story to remember
because we tend to think of Greece
because of its modern geography.
As that peninsula of which there is
a sub Peninsula at the bottom is the
Peloponnesian.
That was not the Greece of antiquity.
If you had to pick a central focus of
where the Greeks were it would be in the
Aegean Sea.
So that's useful to remember.
Then as you move east
along that coast you go.
You come to the Gallipoli Peninsula all
of which is now Turkey and for the rest
of what I'm going to
be saying for a while.
It'll be Turkey as well but through
the straits the Dardanelles the sea of
Marmara.
Bosphorus Greek cities
all over on both sides.
If you keep going east
you hit the Black Sea.
If you move northwards along the
Black Sea and southwards as well.
Greek cities not in the same number they
are fewer than they are in the places
I've mentioned so far but important ones.
For instance when you get up to Crimea
the chief city we call
is such as Sebastopol.
That comes from Greek words means
separate us Polis the sacred city so named
after Augustus by Greeks who lived there
after the Emperor Augustus had achieved
power.
But it was always inhabited by Greeks.
Similarly Odessa the
chief city of Ukraine.
Apart from Kiev was a Greek city and
likewise on the northern shore of Turkey
there are Greek cities to be
found one that leaps to mind is I.
How do they pronounce it in Turkish.
Trabzon.
But it was a trap as this was a
trap. No. What was it called in Greek
trip to the peasants wasn't it.
Yeah. Anyway. So.
It's not the Black Sea is not a Greek
lake but there are Greek cities that are
spotted along the coast
now not on the East Coast.
When you get to the Caucasus
you are in Barbarian territory.
So when the when the mythical mission
of Jason and the his his Argonauts goes
sailing out to that territory he is
out there and you know what was it the
Tarzan country or as far as
the Greeks were concerned.
It's just the wilds of
out in that territory.
Remember he marries and brings home a
wife Madea and she of course is like no
Greek woman who ever lived. She
is a witch. She can perform magic
and she can do monstrous things that
you can't imagine a Greek woman doing.
At least the Greeks can't imagine so
that's not Greek territory out there.
Well let's let's get back out into the
agency and we just cross to Asia Minor.
Now if you turn the bend at the southern
end of Asia Minor and begin moving east
there are some Greek cities along in
there. But when you get to what is now.
Lebanon Syria the coastal places there.
Palestine those there are
no Greek cities there.
And that is because during the period
we're talking about those regions were
occupied by civilized powerful people
who simply would not be pushed aside and
nobody would even dream of trying
to take them on and building
cities that would challenge
their control of that area.
So there are no Greek cities as you
keep coming down and pass Palestine you
reach Egypt and of course Egypt is one
of the great empires of antiquity going
back into the perhaps well certainly into
the fourth millennium prob possibly to
the fifth by no means as
powerful as it used to be.
Far from it it has been conquered.
By now by other peoples.
If you're talking about the year 750 or
something like that it's I think it's in
the hands.
I think it's in the.
Well it is in the hands of the Assyrians
and it will ultimately fall into the
hands of the Persians.
So.
That is not territory that
you can build colonies in.
You've got powerful empires to deal with.
There is one exception in the sixth
century I think it's around margin around
550 or something like that the Greeks
settle a single colony in the delta of the
Nile of Egypt at a place called Knock
crap artists and the root of that word is
ship.
It is a completely different thing from
the Apple key I've been talking about.
It is a trading post and it's there by
permission of and under the protection of
the king of Egypt.
And that's because he wants it's handy
for him to have a merchant settlement of
Greeks for him to do business with.
So that's a great exception
to everything I've been saying
going west would you believe when
you get into what is now Libya.
There was a Greek a very important
Greek colony of Sai Rini and that whole
region was called Cyrenaica and it
was a Greek and you can do that.
You can now you can actually go.
Now that I realize it Libya is now
open it's no longer a closed territory.
You'll see Greek and Roman
temperance there to prove it.
And when you go west however.
It stops in the coast of North Africa.
The reason being the rest of North
Africa is dominated by Carthage.
Carthage is a colony of Phoenician cities
Venetia was located where Lebanon is
now.
It goes back to the maybe the 10th century
maybe the 9th and it was powerful and
it tried to control not only North Africa
but the waters of the Mediterranean in
the West entirely.
The the castle Jennings in fact
have a powerful picked out terror.
In the western part of Sicily and the
Greeks will have to fight the Carthaginian
over the years for control
of the island of Sicily.
So that's how far east they get
and in time the Met the cousin genius
is also cross over into Spain and they
control some portion of the
Spanish coast closest to Africa.
So there are no Greeks there.
They're shut out for the same reasons.
However once you get beyond the cost of
genuine advance into Spain there are now
Greek cities on the coast of Spain and
there continue to be Greek said he's not
everywhere but in a spotty way into
France of which the most important and
famous is the one that the Romans
called mass cilia Marseilles.
Aye aye aye Greektown.
So is niece a Greek town.
This was a victory town and
there are several others.
So the river you they know where to go.
You know the Riviera. Places like that.
Now what about the Italian Riviera.
That's pretty nifty but a Greek colony
is near Portofino where you could put in
one. No. And the reason was
in the northern part of Italy.
There were Etruscans another powerful
ancient people who control their own area
and we're not about to have
anybody colonizing their territory.
However when you keep going south in
Italy past Rome the Romans were not Roman
tradition says the city was found
in 754 three three four five 753.
So. Everybody agrees that
certainly not before that.
So in the period we're talking about
there are no Romans that you have to worry
about but south of Rome there is a
tremendous colonizing of southern Italy.
Greek cities all over the place.
So Greek was that area that when the
Romans do come to dominate most of Italy
and become sort of move up against the
southern region they refer to the whole
southern portion of
that peninsula as Magna.
Great idea great Greece because
they're all Greeks down there.
And then finally down we go
to Sicily and there you have.
The East Coast.
I would say two thirds of the coast of
the island of Sicily is filled with Greek
towns. The third to the West
is on the Carthaginian control.
The inland.
The Greeks don't move in there.
The native Sicilians inhabit
that territory and the
Greeks are not interested
you will find very rare very rare of a
case of a Greek city which is found away
from the sea.
They always wanted to be close to
the sea for varieties of region.
So now I hope you have in your mind a
picture of the way the Greek world had
expanded by the time this wave
of colonisation was complete.
Pretty complete sometime
in the 7th century B.C.
and just a word about the
leading colonizers because
I think there's something
to be learned from that.
One of the things you kind of speculate
about and wonder about why did some
cities send out lots of colonies.
Some cities send out only a few and
others none at all for quite a while.
Well if you see who does
then you may have a clue.
Well here is a list of the
early extensive colonisers.
My lead I mentioned to you from Asia
Minor currents on the isthmus Majora right
next door to cars.
Also more or less on the isthmus then we
turned to the island of Nubia that long
island that's right next to
the east coast of Attica.
You'll be up there there
were two important cities
in the northern part of that
island. One was Karl keys and
the other one was a red area.
And we hear about them relatively early
in the eighth century already being very
important very strong and fighting each
other in a famous war that they fought.
But these cities were very active in
colonizing in a variety of directions.
Lots of these towns sent colonists up
north into the Aegean into the Dardanelles
and so on and beyond.
And some of the same cities send out
colonies to Sicily so that the real
colonizing states.
There was no limit to where they would
send people who wanted to go in those
areas.
It is also interesting to notice who
does not colonize at this early period.
And the answer is place all the most
famous cities of Greece in the classical
period.
Athens doesn't send out a colony until
sometime in the 6th century Sparta starts
at an early point.
Sends out a colony to southern
Italy at some time probably early.
They sent out a colony to an
island in the Aegean Sea Milos.
And then they stopped.
And never sent out another colony.
And finally Thebes the great the
greatest city in Beersheba also does not
colonize. So what can we
speculate is the meaning of that.
What we find is that the states who are
doing most of the colonizing are located
where most of the trade was going on at
this point in history and also most of
the manufacturing.
When I say manufacturing you
understand everything is done by hand.
But you see things like shops that
contain a number of slaves working for a
master.
Some in some cases especially the later
on you go some shops that have quite a
few slaves that work to
produce these things.
It's the handicraft industry but
it's an industry nonetheless.
Well these places are.
The ones that have the trade
the industry and also engage in
in colonization.
Moreover as we will see there will be
internal trouble in the form of political
quarrelling economic
conflict and finally warfare.
Civil wars occur in some of these cities
leading to the emergence and in the
next the next topic I'll turn to the
establishment of tyrannies as the way of
resolving for a time.
These terribly tumultuous conditions
in those cities all of these things are
true of places like Corinth and Mega
and possibly Karl Case and rhetoric.
So.
It is easy to see that where there
is that kind of conflict and trouble.
There would be people who would want
to flee that and to go elsewhere.
And it might well be that the the people
who won those wars internal wars would
have been glad to send them away rather
than to have these discontented people
in these folks who were their enemies
hanging around town and making trouble.
It's only speculation but
it's seems to make sense.
And we know we don't hear of such troubles
within Athens and thieves and Sparta
and it also is possible.
Again it's just speculation that.
Population pressure might well be greater
in cities that did the colonizing they
tended in general not to have as much
farmland as the places that I have
described as not being colonizers who
may not have felt the pressures of land
hunger which was so important
in motivating colonisation.
So though that may explain why some
of the states did and others did not.
Finally what are the consequences to the
Greek experience of this phenomenon of
this outburst of colonisation.
Several things come to mind.
First of all the Greeks now live in
places where they never lived before and
their presence has a real impact in
a different degree in every place.
I would say that typically their
impact was greater in the West.
And the North than it was
in the east and the South.
The reason for that was that in the
east and in South the Greeks lived among
people who were more civilised
than they who were more advanced.
They had very little to teach or to
impose upon those people rather than vice
versa.
I think I would imagine the Greeks
sopping up all sorts of useful and
interesting information from their
neighbors in the east and the south.
And there's no question about it.
If you look at Greece in this period I
don't know if I've used this term before
but some some scholars refer to this
general period talking about as the Greek
Renaissance by analogy to
the Renaissance in Italy.
And there's something to it because
things happen in this period that are
revolutionary in the arts.
In the thinking of people philosophy
is going to be invented in my leaders
probably in the 6th century B.C. when
my leaders was on the main routes to all
of the places where advance knowledge
could be found Mesopotamia Egypt
anybody who looks at Greek mythology
and Greek poetry and Greek stories sees
there is a powerful influence
coming into Greek thought.
From mainly the Mesopotamian direction.
Anybody who looks at the earliest
Greek art for quite some time.
I'm talking about sculpture and temple
building will see the influence of Egypt
enormously powerfully.
So the Greeks are sopping up tremendous
useful information and talent and skills
and all sorts of things that help
explain what's going to become.
It is inconceivable the Greeks could have
developed a civilisation that they did
without contact with these
Eastern civilizations and
learned a great deal from
them. Now people some people
make an enormous jump from that.
And wrongly suggests that what the Greeks
basically did was well if you want to
take the most extreme statement of it
stole and set their civilization from the
other folks.
Well if you take a look at
Greek civilization let us
say in the classical period
those other cultures wouldn't have
had a clue what the Greeks were doing.
So different was the Greek
experience from theirs.
But what is undeniably true is that
the Greeks learned very important and
valuable things and adapted what they
learned to their own way of life and
produce something really quite new and
in many fundamental ways not only new but
the opposite of the places from
which these things had come.
There was also.
Of course some influence of
the Greeks on the people.
They went to an obviously I would start
out by saying this would probably have
been felt most strongly in the West and
in the north where the peoples who lived
there before the Greeks came were not
civilized or not highly civilized they did
not have great urban cultures
and civilizations long
traditions of learning and
so on. No they weren't like that.
The Greeks were ahead of them.
And it's evident that the Greeks they
borrowed stuff from the Greeks that in
every element of life although it
didn't shape their lives in any potent
fundamental way.
But that's the way influence
ran in that part of the world
of course.
Another tremendously important consequence
of colonisation was the growth of
Commerce of trade for the
reasons I've already given you.
But beyond that the Greeks of course
now had access to foodstuffs and other
things out and where they settled which
gave them a basis for trading with a
mother city which meant there were markets
for them out of the city which they
hadn't existed before but also the Greeks
were in touch with people beyond where
they settled so they could obtain raw
materials that were not available before
and also manufactured things that they
might not have had and access access to
before.
All of which they would have used some
for themselves and then engaged in trade
with the old Greek cities.
And you can see in other words you don't
need a very great imagination to see
how this would be a terrific boon to
commerce which means think about it for a
second but what will the business this be.
How will this affect what's happening
in the cities the Poles more and more
people.
And again I want to remind you never
anything approaching a majority but more
and more people would be making their
living in a way that was not agricultural.
They would be in commerce and they would
be an industry in this small sense and
doing all the various
things that are not farming.
And so you now have classes of groups
of people who have interests rather
different from those of the most primitive
poles you could imagine and I would
suggest some scholars early on the
century moved by Marx's theories suggested
that you had a capitalist class.
Growing up.
And that's there's just no
evidence of that. It's just wrong.
My guess is that the earliest
traders of any scope.
Were probably noblemen who also had
landed estates back home but who had the
opportunity to know how the connections
to make it possible to make a lot of
living and trade.
Even so while you don't have a class
of separate people who are just in the
business of making things and making money
you do have people who are engaged in
those activities and who
have some interests that
are different from those the
rest of their people
who are only hotlines.
It is I think part of the conglomerate
of activities you want to keep in your
mind what's going on here is what I'm
really trying to get at socially and
economically and politically you have
to imagine on the one hand the hop light
revolution I do not shrink from saying
that but it's a very debatable term.
What.
Is going on.
That is more and more farmers are becoming
independent self-sustaining hop like
farmers of the kind I've described and
they you can't expect them to continue to
live in the same way as they did before
deferential to their betters that is to
say tugging therefore locks before
they aristocrats and just leaving all
decisions to the aristocratic cow they're
not going to feel the same way about
it.
There's going to be pressure from
them for a better participation in the
decisions that are made in the state.
And also there will be some rich people
very rich people rich in a different way
from the way people used to be
rich rich meant the best land.
Now there will be people who
will have wealth. In the form.
Of precious things. And I would
have I would use the word money.
I'm not going to use the word coinage
because that's very debated and anyway.
There certainly weren't any coins
in Greece as early as say 750.
But that doesn't mean there was no money.
You could have weighed out precious metal
which would be money shekels as in the
Bible originally not coins.
They are quantities weights of something
and come to mean weights of silver or
gold.
So now you have a change in fundamental
economic things is going on.
Well all of this is tied up with this
colonial story I've been telling you.
And finally I think it works
in both directions at the
same time in terms of the
impact all of these changes have on the
political situation on the one hand the
changes that is a the rise of the Hop
like class B the development of lots of
commerce and industry and
wealth and a new kind.
And people who don't fit into the old
traditional society but have a new way has
to be found to fit them in
because as I say they don't fit.
That creates trouble.
And as we shall see very shortly that
trouble often takes the form of first of
factional struggles within the aristocracy
which then after a while come to
involve people outside the aristocracy
which ultimately come to civil war in
which certainly the people who have
become the most important fighting men the
hotlines become engaged on one side or
the other or perhaps sometimes on both.
So that's the what you might say
is the negative side of the story.
But.
Colonization especially some scholars
have pointed out I think persuasively also
for some considerable time provided an
answer to that problem in the form of an
escape valve where you had these people
who were losers and angry and troubled
or people who had in any case were not
happy with the way things were going in
their mother city well they didn't
have to stay and fight it out.
They could go away and they did
in very considerable numbers.
And so one is easily reminded of the
American experience as it has often been
interpreted in which the frontier is
seen to be a tremendously valuable safety
valve to the Americans first as colonists
and then as independent people where
they didn't have the kinds of terrible
class warfare and the terrible warfare
within cities that the Europeans had
experienced throughout most of their
history because really unhappy and angry
people could always go west to get new
places.
I mean fundamentally Kansas is a colony.
In a certain Greek sense.
All of these places are.
So that was that's part of the story
of why America had a very lucky early
history that it had.
And so I think we have to understand
that colonization provided something
analogous to that for the.
For the Greek people. So. Now here we are.
Somewhere in the seventh century.
Most of these places I've been
talking about have been several.
The currents that I have been describing
are flowing and the kinds of problems
they give rise to will be felt in most
of the towns and that is the proper
introduction to the next topic which
I'll discuss next year and next.
It seems like a year but
it's next Tuesday actually.